Madame Pétex Levé,
sorry little bertrand,
Giroud,
Mrs. Ameth,
France Medsport,
Mrs. Meunier Frédéric,
Mrs. Meunier Manon,
Mrs. Mazamalgra.
Many of you know that we are currently in a context
of a pandemic and that we must take these precautions,
a pandemic of racism,
a pandemic of anti-Semitism,
a pandemic of Islamophobia and that therefore,
in the interest of the health of all,
I call on the French,
and particularly the president of the republic and his friends,
not to shake hands at the national gathering.
I met his eyes there.
I saw a kind of,
a kind of challenge,
it will know how to call a sentence of a former president of the republic,
it is break,
poor idiot what basically,
and I extended the hand and there nothing.
So there you go,
I didn't insist on the arm,
it's,
it's politeness.
Maybe as he grows up this boy will learn politeness.
And it is also a sign of the arrogance of certain deputies of France insoumise,
a kind of intolerance.